we have some great discussions happening
on the david pakman show
subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
reddit interestingly because of what the
next story is
one user ethan a says it's time
david does a deep dive into q and
on and um ethan writes at first i
understood the sentiment of not wanting
to give these unfounded insane beliefs
any attention
however that can no longer be the case
and ethan argues that
because so many people are now uh
believing and embracing the q anon stuff
that it's time for me to deal with it
well donald trump seems to also have
embraced it yesterday during a press
briefing
and so we're going to talk about it
today in fact
user katie all the time asks how will
the u.s
deal with the anti-vaxxers refusing the
vaccine when it comes out
saying one of my fears once a vaccine
for the coronavirus comes out
is that a significant minority will
refuse it soon the anti-massacres
will turn into the anti-vaxxers and
refuse the vaccine if let's say 30
percent of the u.s population refuses to
take the vaccine
how will the u.s respond well i i hate
to
burst what is already a very bad bubble
katie
but 40 to 50 of americans as of right
now say they will not
take a coronavirus vaccine so i don't
know the answer
for coronavirus herd immunity based on
its level of contagion
we need about 70 immunity in the united
states
if three or four percent of the country
gets the virus
you've got to get immunity and build
natural immunity if indeed that's the
way it works
you need about 65 66 percent of the
country to get vaccinated if only 40
percent plan
two we have a real problem i don't have
an answer
here in massachusetts the flu vaccine is
going to be mandatory this year
to attend public school a lot of people
are furious they're saying this is
opening the door to mandatory
vaccination
we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show but you're completely right
and in fact
katie i think you are understating the
problem
because it's not 30 so far that have
said i probably won't get the vaccine
it's 40 or even 50 in the polls that
i've seen over the last couple of months
ugly ugly ugly stuff join the discussion
on the david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
let's now deal with this q anon stuff